last episode we had a voicemail from a
listener and there seemed to be a bit of
a debate because Sona and I many other
people in the room thought that he was
authentic in his Persona and his voice
and his style you think that this guy
Conan is maybe doing a bit I felt when I
first heard his voice his name was
Arnold right and he called in I thought
okay I'm listening but then he um he
kind of doubled down and started talking
about his tractor and I thought it felt
to me like an improviser doubling down
on his stick and it reminded me of you
know Brian stack or some of the people
that did great voices that I've worked
with over the years and go into
characters and I thought for a minute is
this like something out of Tom sharpling
where someone's someone's calling in and
and and it just felt like this person
was putting a little bit of mustard on
the fastball and that's when I thought
this might be an authentic this person
may not be real maybe someone's pulling
our chain okay well there's a little bit
of a development in this but first let's
recap the voicemail hear it again so we
can just all get reoriented the listener
as well hi Conan my name is Arnold I was
wondering if it's possible to be
intermittently funny sometimes I nail it
and I think about comedy and like to do
it but other times it just Falls flat
you know but
I was awful wondering last spring dug
myself this little polish here got the
tractor halfway stuck in it's a good old
78 International home still not figuring
out how to pull that out but you get
ideas there's my number here all right
Buckle okay and that was the other thing
it was when he goes like Oh the old 78
International and then he goes like
Buckle I thought
I'm not sure so I'm I was highly
suspicious it's uh we're gonna be able
to get to the bottom of this I think
because we have Arnold on the line oh
[ __ ] are you guys ready no okay I just
so hope he comes on he's like and he
does say like hello yeah I think he's
right Arnold here I hope you fell for my
little scheme did you I'm calling from
the Lawrence Livermore Institute who
I've been working on various
physiological experiments or he's like
hi I'm Arnold okay let's do it let's
bring Arnold on I'm gonna patch him in
now hello
Arnold hi hello is this Arnold it's
Arnold right here oh Hey Arnold this is
Conan O'Brien talking to you what a what
a what a nice surprise hi well this is
well it's a very nice surprise to talk
to you Arnold we got your very nice
voicemail and I thought I'd like to talk
to this gentleman and so here we are
having a nice conversation how are you
sir
um about medium you know you can't have
a good day
medium medium yeah Vindicated medium
medium International Superstar Conan
O'Brien's on the phone with you and you
you're at the medium he's authentic no
no sir let me let me make it really
clear I'm very happy to talk to you just
you know sometimes it's just a straight
line and ain't nothing you can do about
it but
well Arnold I got to admit we listen I'm
going to admit right now we listen to
your uh voicemail and I thought is this
guy putting me on I thought maybe you
were because some people sometimes
people in this world will call a show
like mine
and they'll put on an accent and kind of
a character and I thought is this guy
putting me on and uh and so we wanted to
talk to you to make sure that you are
really Arnold and gosh darn it you are
you are Arnold what's your last name
Arnold
man
what's that
Smith
Arnold my last name is Ed oh yes sir now
I'm doubted now I'm doubting it again
Arnold I think you're Arnold I think
you're an actor and this is a put on
that's what I think you're doing right
now where are you from Arnold
originally from Benton Kentucky there's
a lot of Smiths down there it's like uh
I don't know how high can you count
wow you are from you're from okay so
you're from Kentucky all right well I'm
eating crow right now a nice big nice
Big Slice of crow pie yeah what I'm
having I'm gonna have the whole Crow pie
yeah Kentucky Crow pie
um so you're from Kentucky and and
Arnold grew up yeah yeah oh hey I gotcha
what do you mean you got him oh come on
I borrowed it
you're my writer and uh I'm going for
the original recipe or you're going for
the extra Christmas
extra crispy Arnold
[Music]
I have to ask you something your
question was can you be intermittently
funny and you seem like you're you're
very funny and very authentically funny
so uh and no one no one's got a 100
perfect I don't you I cannot think of
one person in the history of the world
show me all the funniest people in the
world who were always funny every second
so I think everybody's intermittently
funny even the funniest people in the
world so
um I I like your style I really do I
think you're a very amusing fellow I try
I just I like it's nice to see people
smile interact with them oh that's very
nice well what about his tractor yeah
what about the old 78 International is
it in the pond yeah did you get it out
no it's not in the pond no more that
damn thing or Rosie gives me trouble
sometimes I don't know
okay Rosie would still be the tractor I
hope I hope that's not someone else
who's giving you trouble Arnold what
year were you born if you don't mind me
asking I was born in 66. okay oh so
you're dating a younger woman Miss Rosie
the 78 International yeah
well it's a
1486 model uh I guess I'll tell you a
little about it yeah sure yeah it's got
a it's got 16 forward speeds and eight
backwards speeds it's got a wait a
minute 10.1 Arnold why does it need 16
forward speeds what that just feels
excessive doesn't it doesn't it do you
use all 16 forward speeds or be honest
have you mostly used two
I would have to tell you that in all
honesty I've never worked the whole
range of course not maybe one time one
time I think I I just but once but
what would be a circumstance where you
need to use the 16th speed tractor
chicken oh right yeah yeah
I don't know about that one but have you
seen the movie Footloose Arnold where
they play tractor chicken and they drive
their tractors right at each other and
the last one to turn away wins
maybe a long time ago I kind of forgot
it's been a while all right if you watch
footloose and you watch the scene with
tractor chicken you would not forget it
Arnold so
yeah it does you're right that's
something that would stand out but in
Top Gear top speed like maybe 20 21
miles an hour if you're lucky yeah yeah
I've been stuck behind some tractors on
the highway a couple times and in L.A
yeah they're not moving no I like to
drive to rural areas and find tractors
and get behind them and then just really
ride the bumper and and act real
impatient and when old Gus tries to get
me tries to wave me ahead you go on
ahead you go around there's no car
coming I just stay right behind him and
lean on that horn because I hate
agriculture Arnold I hate the growing
and producing of food to feed Humanity
it just gets my goat are you a farmer
not anymore but you grow corn for a
while and all that but uh oh I forgot to
tell you about the tractor it's got a uh
it's got like a people aquarium on it
you know big Square kind of glassed in
spot
did not operate wait a minute
it's glass oh you have scooping people
up with your truck yeah we're getting
them in an aquarium yeah I'm curious
about this Arnold you say that you drive
the tractor and there's a people
aquarium on it oh yeah it's like the cab
but it looks more like an aquarium than
a cab man it's just a thing
I love that you said there's something I
forgot to tell you about the tractor
when it's clear Arnold there's probably
nothing you haven't told us about this
tractor
I know how many speeds it has I know
it's it's top mile per hour I know its
name well I could give you some more oh
yeah okay okay I can't I Dare You Arnold
let's have it all right get ready for
this so it's got it can do tandem wheels
in the back singular okay all right yep
you can get like a four-wheel drive
two-wheel drive uh Arrangement just
depends on you know how much you are
you're in the thick of it working so
again you know I just got the four by
two not because that's what all you need
is the four by two right now you know
what I mean you said you're not farming
you're not really in the thick of it
right now
so you just stick with the 4x2 you know
that's all you need at this point
everything anything else is overkill in
my opinion Arnold
um well you are a you Arnold you are a
uh you're a fine gentleman I'm sorry
that I doubted your authenticity when
you left the message that that is me uh
showing uh my own Frailty
and weakness I've been in the comedy
world too much too long and I've worked
with too many people who love to do
various accents you're cynical uh maybe
I'm a little cynical and people people
call you know and I thought well here's
a guy who's putting on I right away
nailed it as Kentucky I knew that and I
was like but I thought it was a comedic
artist uh giving me the Old Kentucky
spieleru Arnold I want you to know that
Sona and I never doubted you that's true
did you get Kentucky rolled or something
there I did I got Kentucky rolled back
in the day you know I want to talk about
it there was a period in my life where I
roamed the country Barefoot
um and all right all right yeah it was
and I I spent some time in Kentucky and
yes sir I got Kentucky rolled so
let's see if there were something else I
was thinking about I won't touch on
these and I I definitely identified with
you talking about being a skeptic I'm
kind of a orange skip myself oh
you know just not so quick to be uh
agreeable all the time and really just
watch and learn yeah I like that
approach to life
I think that that's why when I first
heard your voicemail I thought really is
this some guy
you know pretended to be Arnold who
isn't really Arnold and uh but I learned
a lesson and I hope you did too that
when you reach out and you talk to the
real you talk to the real person
um you realize that uh that you know
there's a lot of authenticity out there
in the world we just have to look for it
and be prepared and I should not I
should not be as suspicious as I was and
I think Matt and Sona have shown me the
right way to be oh God that's weird I
don't like that it's no no problem yeah
I mean I'm just it's tough for me just
you know I've uh I just had I could
learn from these two and I think I've
been around too much comedy I'm read too
many books I'm too smart they're so
talented
what would you say the thing about
comedy is does it make it too smart to I
don't know I mean there's like education
there's live education learn about
people and the way they act I don't
think it has anything I think it's in
you I think uh comedy is in you and I
think it doesn't have much of of
anything to do with education doesn't
have much of anything to do with
preparation there's there's uh real the
funniest things in the world just happen
conversationally with people and you're
a funny guy Arnold and so you I think
you are 95 of the way there so you don't
need to be thinking about I appreciate
that I just I was thinking it just it's
just the thing that comes out you know
maybe
sometimes I feel like in a weird way I'd
lose control of it it just gets going
and uh
that's the good stuff Arnold that's the
good stuff sometimes you're up there on
Rosie and you're you're clicking along
and
35th gear and uh
we're doing 140 miles an hour and you've
driven through no no you've driven
through seven Billboards and uh
you you get doing some of your you know
telling one of your style one of your uh
stem winders and then the next thing you
know it's yeah you want to go too far
that's the idea it's your whole career
yeah Mike my whole career has been well
I've been known to a fan because I go a
little too far it's hard to tell who's
offended who is a fan of bull is that
yeah well that's more that's more and
more an issue all the time Arnold but uh
you know but as long as you have a good
yeah but as long as you have a good
heart and you're not trying to hurt
people
um if someone gets offended you can
usually straighten it out with them and
and apologize so I think uh keep I'll do
my best yeah keep doing you Arnold you
do you it's uh you know that's the way
to go you got the right idea yeah well
it was very nice talking to you sir
really nice talking to you and uh
um thanks so much for calling into our
show we really do appreciate it
all right can I give you a little
Kentucky roll here sure
yeah hello
that was it
that's it
[Music]
that's it hello
yeah there it is and you signed off with
bucko right I'll say that sometimes
that's kind of you know that's how you
signed off on the on the voicemail you
went okay bucko I like bucko yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of a kind of a thing
where it is
Buckle I like how you you really get
that oh working for you Buckle I love it
it's a solid shape it rolled all right
well Arnold you're the master and you've
taught me well thank you very much sir
all right good talking to you Conan it's
been a really nice talk it's been a
great talk thank you Arnold take care